[Music]
thank you
Tim you tweeted yesterday that this
legislation was the worst piece you've
seen in 18 and a bit years as an MP tell
us why
because it's based on loads of bogus
information I think it's entirely
legitimate to have a different point of
view the majority of things I've had to
vote on there's about 18 and a half
years including many when I was actually
on the government side are things I
didn't agree with but I think the the
legislation that is being pinged and
ponged between the two houses of
Parliament at the moment is based on all
sorts of assumptions that are false
um the uh essential understanding that
you know we are in a worse position than
anywhere else that people are heading
straight for the United Kingdom and yet
the reality is 70 of people who flee
um their home country as refugees stay
in the next door country an Ever
decreasing fraction of people uh move
further and further away a small
minority come to Europe a very small
minority come to the United Kingdom and
many of those by the way uh who come
over the channel to the UK
um will do so and we'll not be refugees
it's a minority the government's own
figures show it's a minority of about
one in five but we'll never know that if
we don't process them so having a policy
a piece of legislation that he
essentially says we're going to assume
everybody is bogus bracket when our own
figures know that 80 aren't and
therefore break all sorts of
international understandings in the
process it's essentially tackling one
small symptom of a colossal Global
problem and doing it badly on the basis
of wrong information so it's not just a
decision I disagree with most of them
are those it's a decision I can't have
any respect for because it's based on a
total bogus misunderstanding or rather I
don't think the government are
misunderstanding it at all they know
these facts and figures and they choose
to do what they're doing because they
think it has some political benefit for
them so it's very hard to respect
um those behind it Tom what's all your
response to that I mean there are some
claims I mean Tim made them yesterday in
his speech in the comments was that
perhaps here has been sort of over egg
but to an extent my ministers what's
your reaction to all of that you know I
was I'm glad to support the bill happy
to support the bill
um you know very happy to vote against
you know 18 laws amendments yesterday
um I think it's needed I think this is a
great concern to my constituents uh they
want us to have control of our borders I
think there's a majority of people in
this country you want us to have control
of his borders and I think to do that we
need to have a deterrent
um and I think the important point is
you know these are overwhelmingly seem
to be single men who can afford to pay
people Smugglers who have come through
multiple safe European countries uh
before they've illegally entered our
country we've got to have a robust
approach I think this bill does that I'm
happy to support it and Tim made a point
of the speech yesterday which was that
you know if every country starts doing
this you know in terms of uh closing
down these legal routes I mean that
could cause the whole collapse of the
system is that not a real issue
particularly when Britain won some of
the figures is not taking as many as say
Germany for instance yeah I mean I'd
also say actually talking about Germany
that actually is acceptance rate for
refugees is actually quite a bit low
other than it is in the UK when it comes
to claims it's got an interesting point
but I tell you where I've just been I've
just been with um iom talking about the
rohingya refugee situation I've been to
rohingy cap three times myself and and
and people I was speaking to told me
that um some other other countries us uh
Canada uh nothing now even Australia and
New Zealand will be taking uh to
refugees from from Iranian refugee camp
so that I can see what's happening
globally I'm very aware that we have a
duty to be generous towards genuine
refugees uh Freedom persecution and I'm
forgot for a moment saying that I don't
want us to be generous but we have to
have a but we have to have a managed way
of doing it we've got to have a controls
we've got to have a system of doing it
and I think if we if we have control of
it and we have a system that has
integrity at its heart I think the
British public will get behind it
because they are compassionate but what
they don't want to see is tens of
thousands of people jumping the queue
and arriving here illegally which is
what has been happening I mean Tim you
proposed uh having more safe and legal
routes to do this I mean is that really
the case I mean surely critics of that
will just say we're rewarding criminal
Behavior effectively
well no you bypass criminal Behavior it
says if for example when I did a visit
with a conservative and labor MPS to
Calais last year we met one of the
conservative MPS for Calais
um for whom obviously it's a huge
problem for him locally but he was
thinking about the situation Beyond his
community as well
in France there's a there's quite an
appetite amongst you know sensible
politicians of all different political
flavors for allowing people to apply for
asylum in the United Kingdom from a
place in France so you don't need to
cross the channel to do so and here's
the thing really the the fact is that a
real deterrent would be if we had a
system that worked in the end what this
really is all about is the pictures of
people crossing by boats but also the
awareness there's 177 000 people at the
last count in temporary accommodations
of which are hotels around the country
that's because the government's not
managing the situation now I don't know
the situation or the details of uh what
happened to the many more refugees that
there are in Germany than there are in
the UK and if there's a lower Grant rate
maybe it's because they actually process
their refugees whereas we don't process
ours those that we do process by the way
turn out 80 to be actual refugees and
one of the problems is that we you know
jumping the queue I hear the point and
but the simple reality is any Refugee
who runs away is in a sense jumping the
queue they are seeking to kind of get a
better life and to run away from war and
persecution and all the rest of it 99 99
government figures of Eritrean refugees
people who come to the United Kingdom by
whatever means normally buy votes turn
out to be genuine refugees we know
anything about Eritrea that would not
surprise you however there is not a
single safe route there is no
resettlement program there is nothing
equivalent to Ukraine Afghanistan Syria
or Hong Kong which by the way are the
only places you can legally come from
now as a result of this bill so what are
we saying to those people
um who are victims of Africa Kim Jong-un
basically similar kind of situation
there we're saying we will not help you
and so we've got to have a system which
allows us to provide Sanctuary for those
who desperately need it and not play up
nonsense that makes out that somehow
Britain is a wash if you put Britain
back into the EU for League table
purposes per capita with 22nd at 28 in
terms of the number of people we take um
as Asylum Seekers I I think in in many
respects I think to those who
um you know don't feel as though as a
country we've taken enough refugees I
think it would be very legitimate for
them to say look we should take more and
we should
um we should have more safe and evil
roots and this is sort of what the cap
would be roughly because I'm assuming
we'd be a cat I can't imagine anyone who
really would be young cat
um but but at the same time realize that
we we can't have a situation where we
have tens of thousands people turning up
illegally but these are dangerous
Crossing so we must deter But ultimately
when we talk about safe and legal routes
um I labor for example talk about seven
Eagle Roots they talk about they need to
be a capital and say what the cap should
be whatever it should be but my view is
if you could apply into if you could
apply for Asylum
um in the UK from another country I
think quite quickly that cap would be
reached quite quickly would be reached
um and then we could be back at square
what with people who you know who who
think they're SMGs but the Cap's been
reached for that year save as an annual
cap who will then continue to make
um dangerous Crossings across the
channel there's a reality to the
situation which is we have potentially
um tens of millions have been across
across the world he could potentially
claim to be Refugee or get Refugee
status we can't take all of them
we're a small item therefore we we do
need to have a cap and and if we have a
cap if there is a cap then we have to
think about how we prioritize
and I just happen to think
uh the the so for example some of the
rohingya refugees I've met three times
mainly women and children perhaps
slightly higher up that priority list
than mainly single men who have come
through multiple safe European countries
um and actually the the Indian refugees
that I met don't have the opportunity to
shop between different safe European
countries about where I want to go and
actually
seeking a better life is different from
fleeing persecution
yeah but it isn't one of the issues of
this legislation is that it's so black
and white in terms of the exemptions it
puts down that those kind of individual
you know excrucially of those cases
where you might have a heart you know
release a personal story about someone
who's overcome you know such adversary
adversity and face terrible things that
we can't even think of they're going to
sort of all those kind of opt-outs are
going to be taken out by this bill and
that's their real problem here but I
think it's a really important thing you
know if you are in a desperate situation
involve fleeing persecution then
apply for asylum in your first safe
country
you know it's important to realize that
all of these individuals have been in
front which is safe where they could
have claim this island before they got
to France presumably we were in for many
other and safe European countries many
of them are coming to the UK not
necessarily because they want to be safe
because they're safe in France but
they're coming to the UK for perhaps for
other reasons which is why I probably
encourage them to look at our Point
space in the Greek immigration system
and come here legally it's not break our
immigration Tim what's your response to
that then I mean I'm surely as Tom said
I mean the argument put forward by
conservative MPS is that why aren't they
just stay in the first safe country
oh nearly three calls them do 70 to do
um so but are we to say that you know
Lebanon for example has got to take
absolutely everybody a hundred percent
of people gonna stay next door come off
it so the reality is first of all most
people do exactly that secondly there is
on the United Nations convention you are
not obliged to stop at the safe for a
safe place for perfectly good reasons a
because it would mean some country would
bear and even more unfair burden than is
currently the case and secondly people
often have good reason to be somewhere
else so you might when I meet people who
are refugees who are heading towards the
United Kingdom it's because they're ex
British colonies very often and see as
they as the motherland they see or or
they have family relations uh here and
and other connections but the thing is
this so first of all
um most people do stay in the next door
country
secondly they don't have to under U.N
law and we should be grateful for that
and then thirdly there is a trickling
down if you like as you as people
predominantly for coming from the whole
of Africa find their way onto Mainland
Europe it's a minority that do and
people stop along the way so is France a
safe country yes it is and the massive
majority of people who go to France stay
in France and and France could easily
say right Britain said we're not taking
people from France they can all clear
off back to France they'll come in the
first place we'll not even process them
we'll even look at where they are or not
refugees and France could say right same
to Italy same to Spain they're safe
countries too and then what have you got
breakdown of the International System so
you've got one of two things well
actually you know both of two things
will happen one is Britain becomes more
of a pariah internationally it becomes
less significant less influential seem
as a bad team player and secondly at the
same time you'll have some people who
will copy us so you have a combination
of Britain being further reduced in its
standing and Effectiveness and influence
in the world and secondly you'll have to
break down the existing pretty tenuous
system that already exist so I just
think it's incredibly foolish and based
upon all sorts of false premises and by
the way there's no scheme to another
rohingus coming here either in the end a
competent government would assess those
people who arrive here and would send
back the ones that are not refugees and
you only know that if you assess them by
the way people crossing on boats is a
thing we really don't want but one thing
people have got to understand this is
what's so frustrating and it shows such
a lack of being basic Research into
what's going on out there if you fled
from Sudan for example and you have
worked your way through
Libya which is an appalling place is a
reminder that no situation is ever so
bad you can't make it worse you know the
Gaddafi's time in Libya almost seems
like a dream compared to what it is like
there now it is a hell hole for people
passing through it so you have somehow
got through Libya you have crossed the
Mediterranean on a flimsy vote you've
had whatever you've had through Europe
as you've headed towards family or the
mother country in the UK I'm afraid a
few miles on a boat over the channel
which seems terrifying to you and me
it's not a lot compared to the horror
that they have been through already
which is why we should be looking at
providing safe routes much further down
the line not even in France further back
I'm just I'm just really I'm really
interested by this so I'm just imagining
that me me and Tim are putting in the
room for a day we are the government me
and Tim and we have to come up with a
solution to this to this issue uh I I
think that
um you know I do have I am compassionate
towards one US wanting to help refugees
I'm I'm
okay we both want to stop Small Boat
Crossings Tim says a way to do that is
to have a more safe and legal Roots but
I want to understand more how this would
work so what I would mean in practice is
you could claim for a Asylum for Refugee
status in the UK from from from anywhere
across the world presumably
and I'd also want to know from Tim
roughly what sort of cap would he be
looking at would it be uncapped would it
be capped on an annual level what did
what do you think a generous Refugee cap
would look like
well the government doesn't know and
there would be no cap from the
government's perspective either because
in the end uh what is being proposed is
to effectively take anybody who arrives
here irregularly
um and because he's not illegal and
under international law is irregular
um anybody who arrives here irregularly
would eventually be taken to Rwanda
that's an uncapped number so the
government I have an uh the government
have an uncapped number of Asylum
Seekers that the UK taxpayer will pay
for through the Rwanda system okay so I
what I think and you won't get it you
know that what I think
Tim is therefore saying is that anyone
if they believe that they're a refugee
should be able to and free to apply to
be get Refugee status in the UK from
wherever they are in the world and they
shouldn't be a cap and potentially if
that means that we have
um over a million applications that are
successful
but a million extra refugees we take
that year as the UK is there a point
where you'd introduce a capital
so there is no well so there's no cap on
your proposal so the United Kingdom
could very easily take a million people
under the illegal immigration bill that
with the United Kingdom government and
the United Kingdom taxpayer is
responsible for
um to Warehouse in the United Kingdom
because you'll have to do that because
there's no way you're going to get the
numbers of people you think you are to
Rwanda just um logistically and but the
place we start so this glorious
Coalition of you and me in government
dealing with this Tom the first thing we
do is admit it's an awful lot harder and
a lot more difficult and be an awful lot
more grown up about it than the guru and
his current government is being there is
not an easy answer and it does involve
much better policing of our Shores or
more importantly of the French Shores
working with them to make sure these
don't come across they're in line mine
up until about well up until really the
pandemic a little bit beforehand there
wasn't a huge small boat Crossing uh
industry for two or three reasons one is
there wasn't such good policing of the
channel tunnel and people were coming
that way and then secondly once that
unsafe route was closed up people found
other unsafe routes to manage to come
across and so the the reality is that
we're dealing with a demand that is out
there and how do you do it in a in a
manageable and mature way and that's why
being part of the International
Community and behaving like it is the
way you police the numbers but the idea
that there's going to be a million
people coming when we already take only
a quarter of what Germany takes only
seven percent of all of the eu's
um refugees is a reminder that this is a
problem but it's not the kind of
Emergency the United Kingdom government
is making out that it is and so my
accusation really is the government
knows this and rather than being mature
about the problem and acknowledging that
is a difficult problem with tough
solutions that involved more than one
solution is going for something
simplistic that won't work and threatens
Britain's status around the world and is
also inhuman I need to ring this
discussion to a close but let me just
give the last word to you tell them
where do you see this bill going we're
going in the final stages of ping pong
um it looks like you might have another
late night uh next Tuesday on it I mean
frankly do you think that with the
Amendments Etc is it going to work
um I think I think we'll get ruin a sin
uh for really ending all the research
and before the summer recess and I think
I think that the the the the essence the
ethos of the bill will be intact uh but
for this bill to be effective clearly it
will be working in tandem with people
underskine and we'll hear about that uh
um before we close the year we hope um I
do think that potentially in addition to
around we need to be thinking about some
other kind of deterrent to go
potentially in tandem with Rwanda or
instead of I think that's quite
important but really you know what I
think the majority of people in this
country want when it comes to our
immigration and Asylum policy is net
legal migration to be at slightly lower
more sustainable levels when it comes to
our Asylum policy I do think there's a
majority in this country in favor of
compassion but they want a controlled
approach and a controlled system which
we do not have at the moment
thank you
[Music]